we make way for the CFL legend the
former NFL quarterback Shawn Salisbury
that's the only time you'll ever use me
in the name legend but I always loved it
it always starts with the CFL big huge
contributor to the CFL you're a big
believer level don't you owe us your CFL
Jersey so I could put it on a man cave
and I'm not only am i sinning - CFL
Jersey but you know what I did I went
had a coffee cup printed with my face on
it and the name of my show for you so
you could put her see right there in
front of Bobby Knight oh I'm not gonna
do know that you're not gonna do both no
just one I don't want your face up you
don't know all these years of the love
your right shoulder that's Lou - put the
red sweater yeah it looks like Bobby
Knight okay Lou Holtz Bobby Knight all
right
but okay the jerseys it but I thought
that maybe you'd like to wake up to me
every morning make your own coffee Kelly
will drink out of your console or knows
what's been in your coffee cup first
reaction when you heard Patriots and Cam
Newton upgrade the if comes in front of
it - Dan you get a guide no risk all
reward up to seven and a half million so
the no guarantees no money involved he's
31 he's angry feels disrespected when
you when you drawn up a quarterback and
say I'd really like him to look like
that that's that that's who you draw up
Cam Newton so the question is how does
he fit in Josh McDaniels challenge now
is it for 20 years that system and Josh
over the last handful of years has had
one guy Brady and that systems only seen
drop back now the challenge and it's
kind of a good one that that you get to
add some things to Brady didn't bring so
what Tom lacked in you get in cam so Dan
I don't know the risk this is a guy
that's a 25 million-dollar talent that
you're getting for the price you'd pay a
guy who's just a guy and he's not just a
guy I think it's an upgrade and if Cam
Newton's healthy and he processes
information quickly
this will be the best or should I say
the most underrated offseason move of
the year that's how good he can be the
question is Willie and you go back to
what Carolina did and they smartly put
in the language that cam had it Auburn
just to make it because you come in as a
rookie and you know this they throw
everything at you and you're just trying
to simplify things now he goes to New
England where they haven't catered
anything to him
it was a Tom Brady system and I'm
curious how you how do you change your
often maybe it's maybe they were
changing with Stidham in there in the
first place so maybe it's not that much
of a shift but explain that to to us on
what that's gonna feel like and what's
what's their offense gonna look like the
base their verbage Dan's gonna stay the
same and that's why you know how
sometimes change gets people rejuvenated
like cam a change to New England which
is an upgrade like I said you may not be
Brady but he's really talented is what
happens is it's like an addendum to a
contract you're gonna do what you do
base wise but we're gonna add things and
we're at the time I'm so I'm so tired of
the coaching staffs that say you're
gonna do it my way or it's just not
gonna work here look what Andy Reid did
he took some wood Kingsbury did utilize
some of Pat's skills in college applied
to what he does and said well why
wouldn't we cater and make things for
this guy's comfortable look what
Baltimore did Lamar Jackson he's the MVP
of the league so it's gonna be incumbent
upon Josh McDaniels and Belichick to say
okay here's what we do but you know what
for smart purposes 2020 has also been
different with no off seasons let's just
make things a little simpler and add
some packages for him to get him on the
edge
what is he comfortable with the verbage
doesn't have to be where it's with four
sentences long like the old West Coast
offense so now it's a challenge on the
coach I love coaches that are willing to
say well let's take 12 coaches and
adjust to 53 or 56 or 60 players as
opposed to the other way around
so the challenge now falls on Belichick
and Belichick to let McDaniels know
listen we've got a freak show skill set
here let's utilize what he does not
square peg round hole and he's not gonna
be as accurate as Brady he's going to
give you more vertical create plays
outside the pocket mix in a little R
appeal down hill inside zone run and if
he can give me 60 to 62 percent
make the big play that maybe Tom's not
at that point of makin now you get an
upgrade with the legs than you did and
then you do with the arm but you also
get a young guys still at thirty-one
who's still got some times this is where
you get your best football in your early
thirties so the challenge is for both
but go into this take the ego out of it
like Baltimore like Kansas see and cater
to the guys skill set doesn't mean you
change everything but you do need to
change some things to operate out of
what he does and you're not gonna make
Tom Brady run the option and you're not
gonna make Cam Newton be Tom Brady you
replace in the goat big shoes but camps
got big shoes he's gonna be fine I was
wondering I thought the Chargers were
gonna sign Cam Newton uh-huh I thought
they would do that incident unless
they're totally sold on Justin Herbert
or they took him as the consolation
prize that you didn't get to us so we'll
take Justin Herbert that's not how you
decide on a quarterback in my opinion
you know the guy you want and you go
after the guy you want
if Chua had fallen to them would they
have just said all right we'll take to
it I don't know that I don't know what
that philosophy is in the draft room but
I thought if I could get Cam in there
it's Los Angeles
and let him go with a lot of those
weapons I thought that was the route to
take because I quarterbacks are about
now got a win now that's a roster that's
great to win now
Justin Herbert might not be ready for a
couple of years Tyrod Taylor's okay Kim
that would have been rolling the dice to
say you know what how about we take over
Los Angeles here oh no doubt and Dan
answer your first question about tua had
the Chargers been able to get him
instead of Miami it wouldn't be like
Herbert Herbert's gonna sit Tyrod Taylor
would have been the backup and Toole
would have started from day one that
would have been the case in LA had to
have been the guy as opposed to Herbert
now with this situation is I don't think
it's an inn I think people were
concerned about how healthy is camp it's
early in the process the draft we Tyrod
Taylor's a guy who protects the football
plays it safe and you've got a lot of
other talent around him so he can kind
of fit in people everywhere any coach
you talk to they trust him you may not
get spectacular but he's not gonna crush
you what you don't want your quarterback
to do with Tam or the risk man would
that's the high reward but we got a guy
like cam
athletic who protects the ball probably
a little more accurate is gonna protect
the ball more and he can be a good
bridge because cam still thinks he's a
full-time starter for the next six years
Tyrod has been in this situation many
times cam has not this is the first time
in his career where he's gonna be
well he's still gonna be the starter in
New England where he would have went
into this situation where tie rod he's
like DeBerg you know Sadler you keep
drafting guys and he'd be good for you
and then you he'd have a good season and
maybe even a Pro Bowl type season but
you'd replace them with the next guy and
what it tells me is it's more of a
compliment to Tyrod Taylor and their
trust for him and they're not knowing
where the Cam Newton health situation
was and if Cam could handle maybe be in
a backup if it didn't turn out he's not
gonna have to deal with that Stidham is
gonna have to be the guy to beat out Cam
and in and in and in LA it's just a
matter of time and Tyrod Taylor will
determine how long he holds that job or
if he's playing somewhere else because
Herbert is not ready to start football
wise just football wise and I know you
can't separate it who's more of a risk
Cam Newton or Colin Kaepernick Colin
Kaepernick is now I think Kaepernick
should get a chance if he can go in and
do it we work out and the key for Colin
does he love football still Dan listen I
made football look hard and that's
playing every year so you know now he's
far more gifted but my point is and I
was talking to Warren Moon about this
very thing that the dedication it takes
stand to beat those guys that are so
good that sustained greatness do you
want to be a guy or do you want to be
the guy and so that's what Colin's got
to decide I don't think his skill sets
them to the point where it just doesn't
exist he's physically strong he can rip
it the question is does he want to put
the time in and does he feel he can with
all that off the field stuff that he's
doing activism does he want to devote
himself to being great and being the guy
cuz after four years off you better be
devoted to it and there's less risk and
can because he's physically passed a
physical he played it some times last
year so he's been around football more
so to me while Colin's so tempting
because of his skill set I don't know
worried for four years dan also we see
is that the video of him throwing on a
field we don't know and I want to hear
from him I always say everybody telling
me how good he can be and he should be
playing and I get it he should and
deserve an opera
to compete but I don't know where his
head is this do I love it am I willing
to study at 10 o'clock at night six days
a week to be great or do I just want to
be a guy who makes a roster that's up
for him to decide but right now much
higher risk was Colin just as a football
thing because cams been in the league
recently and remember now we're looking
at a guy who is an MVP who's been an MVP
and he's only 31 and he's pissed that
could mean something for the New England
Patriots you know your longest career
run in the NFL under 20 yards but over
ten eleven yards dude you cannot date
listen don't coach that out of me you
can't coach 11 your longest run in the
CFL 59 yards 15 legend blue bomber blue
bomber 88th Grey Cup champions and you
know what else Dan got you one thing
they never did when they signed me on
when they work me out said Shawn get on
the edge you didn't have the are in RPO
right no they did not they all said they
said Shawn does that hat fits you well
and can you chart that's they said how
much thought did you give into how you
looked on the sidelines when you were a
backup quarterback are you kidding me
wristbands were perfect by I licked my
fingers walking up and down the
sidelines just said oh I was ready the I
black had to be adjusted you know hey
how's it look good the hat which hats
right then the long mullet I had Dan it
was dangling out of my hair not a helmet
I had to think well what's that look
like right now while Madden's talking
about Warren Moon on the field and I'm
charting plays and telling Lauren how
great he is yeah damn right I wanted it
to look good okay damn right it's good
to talk to you as always great to talk
to you brother thank you that's a Shawn
Salisbury Sports Talk 790 in Houston
does the morning drive show and then a
former NFL quarterback and certainly a
friend of the show